hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV I  have two ideas for stimulating the  economy even more than John Holmes was  stimulated in saturday-night beaver the  first is hire two people to dig holes  and then hire three to fill it in you  might even throw a management oversight  committee in there as well and we'll  have full employment in no time at all  plus we'll have a lot of big holes and  holes filled in or how about this it's a  simpler idea and it might take power out  of Washington but why don't you just  give the money back in the form of tax  cuts business people and individuals  know better how to spend their money  they know better how to bank their money  and they know better how to invest their  money than anybody in the greater DC  area ever could figure out and it might  actually help the economy